on peut pas manifester maintenant pour
la palicine alors pourquoi on a parce
que ceux qui manifestent vous vous
pensez queon est pro hamass alors qu'on
est pas non non non pas du tout je vais
vous dire franchement d'abord ça a été
interdit au début parce que que votre
Ministre intérieur ne veut pas non mais
je vous donne ma position en toute
sincérité un je pense qu'il y avait un
délai de descence il y avait une attaque
terroriste c'était pas bon après je
regarde partout comment ça se passe en
Europe regardez dans toutes les
capitales où il y a des manif il y a des
éléments très durs qui arrivent et qui
font les les pires trucs c'estàdire il y
a il y a des gens qui veulent
manifester de manière pacifique mais
dedans se gr des éléments hyper radicaux
qui vont aller brûler des drapeaux
d'Israël défendre le Hamas et cetera
est-ce qu'on a envie de voir ça
maintenant moi je pense que on a plutôt
envie de se regrouper moi je suis prêt à
avoir ces explications c'est beaucoup
plus utile de faire ce qu'on fait nous
d'avoir une voix qui défend la paix
l'arrêt des hostilités la lutte contre
le terrorisme et manière ciblé et
respect des populations civiles c'est
beaucoup plus efficace que de se
déchirer ou